So, here I have a folder on my computer
with a bunch of photos. Now, you'll notice that
the message in these photos is all jumbled up,
we can't quite read it just yet. Now, if I
zoom into these photos, you'll notice that the names
of the photos, they have numbers in them. And it's
our task to remove those numbers. And I wrote
a program that does just that. Let me run it.
The output window shows all of the files that were renamed and if I look at the
folders again, you'll notice that the photos have
been renamed. Their names don't have any numbers in
them anymore. Also, if I zoom out just
a little bit. You'll notice that the photos are
now revealing a message. Which in this case
is just, SOME SECRET MESSAGE. Let's build this program.